the chat on this. All right so we are ready and going everybody's muted and we had some questions
come in on genetics that I want to touch on and everybody and everybody that if they did a
23andMe and we have that yet called over those results with you that you call the clinic and make
sure that we get scheduled to go over those results and they will tell you did you get your results
back from 23andMe again as I post on the Facebook page we do not get notification from 23andMe
if you did your genetics through 23andMe they only notify you and they notify you via email
that your results are in it and then we will need to download the raw data from their sites and
we'll need your user to be password to do so. If you did your genetics through us through the new
genetic test that we have that is different we get the results back and we will let you know
when they're ready so that is the that is the difference. Okay so we will go right into this
and get started. All right so other thing I want to a little bit prior to that for those that are
local to us if you have friends or family that want to do a thermography we are doing our special
the same special that we did last year the $50 off the breast kids are awareness for the breast kids are
awareness for October we're doing it September October November to get your initial and your
follow-up if you have any local friends that want to do that you can book now. Don't get into the
questions the first question does or can your genetic analysis program combine both husband and wife
results to show potential weaknesses or potential defects for children and we can't do that. So you
can look you can do a graph on you know the old genetic graph that you learned in college of
XY and XY and here's the mother and here's the father and what's the chance that the kids have
knowing the knowing the genetics of the mother and the father you could extrapolate some data to know
that the percentage chance that a child is going to have defects on certain genes like if the if the
mother has a two of their empty HFR gene or the father has a two of their empty HFR gene that means
they're positive positive that you know the children are all going to have a two or if the father
is a one and the mother is a one each child has a 50% chance of being a two and a 50% chance of being a
one and if the mother is a one of the fathers zero so it gets more complicated so you could only give
chances that you'd have to extrapolate each gene or the software doesn't do that because it's only
going to give a percentage each child have a percentage chance of having a specific defect
so you can't really do that you can get some ideas if you had both parents so let's say if you're
looking at the ABP1 gene that that detoxifies um it helps you get rid of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs and you have a two and your husband has a two then you know your kids have a
two so they shouldn't be taking an ad mill um at least on a regular basis or a tylenol or
something like that so that would give you some ideas so you would necessarily have to do the test
to find out that one day if you do the father had the mother's genetic profile you'd get a pretty
good idea but to really know your kid's profile they have to do their own genetic profile and that
brings up the question okay well I am a one-year-old can we do a genetic profile in a one-year-old
well technically you can but you can't get them to spit at the tube so in order to collect
enough saliva to run the genetic test they have to be old enough to know how to spit at a tube
um of course your kids are spitting all over the place but you can't get them to spit where you love
the spit so that's kind of the way it is but um so they have to be old enough to be able to spit
at the tube to be able to run the genetic profile but however old that is for your child to know how
to do that that's what you can start running genetic tests on the kids and understand in order to do
a genetic workup on family members remember we have that family special because it's an evidentable
almost every patient that we run genetics on after we go over their genetics they want to run
genetics on family members so we have that availability to make it affordable for families to get
their genes done so make sure you take advantage of that too somebody asked a question
of the chat what causes leg cramping and do you have any suggestions to alleviate that
um just a little bit off subject there but um leg cramping it can be multiple reasons I actually did a
video on it probably about eight or a month ago if you go back and search the Facebook feed
through that but um most common causes of leg cramping are going to be
mineral deficiencies even iron deficiencies different ademias could cause leg cramping
obviously electrolyte deficiency is the most common thing um and dealing with leg cramping is you
take some electrolytes before bed that could be helpful um recessive legs is a little bit different
though it could be tied to that same thing uh leg cramping is a muscular condition so if you're
really talking about charming horses in the legs that's the muscles going into spasm um usually that's
tied to electrolytes so make sure you're getting enough minerals that you're absorbing your minerals
so that also just like everything it ties to leak you got issues and you're taking a good source of
minerals and we talked length about that in other videos too about getting minerals that are
keylated the way plants would keylate minerals uh so taking an organic plant-based mineral is the way
to go um all right back to our subject on genetics another question was are there genetic causes to
cancer uh and there are genetic causes to cancer so that's one our whole book about cancer genes
is about and I would recommend that you uh go to our website and go under the genetic tab of our therapy
tabs and uh go now to see the tab that says cancer genes the book you'll click on it you'll go to this
uh page right here that now has um a whole bunch of videos um there's probably 30 videos so far
cancer genes remember the book that I'm creating with this is a video book for you to watch the
videos and learn about them so but when you usually are talking about causes of cancer with cancer genes
you're talking about oncogenes and tumor suppressor genes now what an uncle gene is uncle is a Latin
prefix for cancer where we get the word oncology uh and gene is your genetic so if there are certain
genes that can act as tumor promoter genes those are called oncogenes certain genes that if there are
defects on that gene it can actually promote tumor growth or promote cancer growth that's what's
called an oncogene though typically there are defects in genes that do other things but the defect
causes it to promote rapid growth so um god didn't give us genes to make cancer but when we have
defects in certain genes it can promote growth uh also the one of the ways that uncle genes
promote growth is certain genes that we refer to as uncle genes that where they have defects they
promote growth they do so by inhibiting tuber suppressor genes so tuber suppressor genes we talk
about genetic causes of cancer um that is the most common thing that we see defects in tuber suppressor
genes so god did give us certain genetics certain genes that are now labeled tuber suppressor genes
because when they turn on they suppress growth so knowing in his sovereignty that we are going to
be living in a fallen world and exposure to all sorts of chemicals and toxins and biochemicals and
all these different things are going to damage cells and damage cell membranes and damage nuclei and
cause uh because of um damage to nucleus to um uh nuclei of cells which are responsible for cell
replication could cause a cell to go into rapid replication that's what cancer is so anything that
gets inside the cell that could affect the replication centers of the nucleus can cause the cell to go
into rapid replication if that does take place and what i should say when that does take place because
this happens on every human being something gets into the cell causes the cell to go into rapid
replication it starts to replicate it is by definition cancer but we are a long ways away from
being diagnosed with cancer at this time because our cells have have ways to combat this in one of the
primary ways to combat this is is the turning on of certain genes called your tuber suppressor genes
your tuber suppressor genes are genes that um suppress uh growth so if there is rapid replication
that's taking place the tuber suppressor genes turn on and cause the cell to go through
apoptosis remember apoptosis is normal program cell death so cause the cell to die so we're going to
kill the cell because it's in rapid replication your tuber suppressor genes turn on and cause apoptosis
so when we're looking at genetic causes to cancer we have to look at these tuber suppressor genes
the most common one that you probably heard of is the bronca genes there are numerous bronca genes the
bronca one of the bronca two gene families we should say so these gene families are tuber suppressor
genes specifically for the the hormonal driven cancers and women mainly so the breast cancer the
ovarian cancer the uterine cancer the endometrial cancer that's where the bronca genes will kick it if
there's any any rapid replication cells the tuber suppressor bronca genes kick it and it turned off
that growth by causing apoptosis causing cell death and therefore you never get a diagnosis of cancer
in truth this has happened to every single woman on the planet it's ever lived they've got cancer
their bronca genes kick on kills the cell you never get cancer so technically did they have cancer
yes they technically had cancer did they ever get diagnosed with cancer no because your body killed it
the way it was supposed to take place the problem comes in is when a person has a lot of defects in these
tuber suppressor genes then they don't kick in very well so that when and if cancer starts to grow
in the breast the bronca tuber suppressor system doesn't kick in because of the defects in this gene
as well as if it didn't have defects in the gene and this person is more susceptible to cancer
don't understand your body has other fail safe methods to kill a growing cancer you have your immune
response you have other tuber suppressor genes many many other tuber suppressor genes I just
used in the bronca as an example here that could kick in and help kill this growing cancer in this
person's breast but there's there's problems that are taking place so when a person has a diagnosis
of cancer we know that apoptosis didn't take place it is not taking place in those cells that's why
they're still growing there's rapid replication taking place in those cells caused by something that got
into just one cell to begin with and it could have been something that got into that cell 40-50
years ago but now has damaged the replication cycle and it sells going to rapid replication
therefore that's what cancer is and there has been a failure in our in multiple fail safe systems
so one of the fail safe systems to keep us from getting cancer are our tumor suppressor systems
so for her for me to get a full diagnosis of cancer and have cancer growing inside of me
there had to be at one point a failure in that system it may not be due to defects in that system
talking about genetic defects in the bronco or the p53 gene or whatever but it could be just
overwhelmed it wasn't able to keep up with this cancer that was growing so rapidly but defects are
a piece of it so genetic defects on tumor suppressor genes can be a cause to cancer or we more
appropriately said can be a cause to a person not being able to suppress a growing cancer so we want
to look at those because there are some nutraceutical interventions one could do if they have defects on
those genes so if I have defects on by p53 gene the most research tumor suppressor gene
but well there are there's research studies that show that using things like
curcumin tumor can really help support the p53 system with my bronca genes there's evidence that
there's specific nutraceuticals that could help support defects in that system it's you know that's
just a way to look at it so wouldn't it be a wise idea to get somebody's genetic profile when they're
15 years old so that boy you have a whole mess of defects on your bronca genes it'd be really good
for you to be taking this product on a regular basis to help support that or you know that's
just wise doctorate I think that's just wise medicine is trying to prevent disease by looking at
every factor that you can I mean we were taught in school you get a really good family history are
there cancers in the family oh my mom had breast cancer at 44 my grandma got breast cancer at what
she was 49 my great grandma had a demetrial cancer which she was in her 30s wow probably pretty good
chance there's some defects in some tumor suppressor genes that are genetically carried out in your family
that are linking these together should we look at those and try to support those systems prior to
you getting cancer so that's why we look at genetics not that genetics are the cause to every
cancer but they're a piece of it just like diet is just like toxins are just like everything else is
so the more ways that you could look at it and I think the better you're going to be able to support
the patient that's why we created these videos so make sure you go to our website that those videos
are available to everybody whether you're a patient or not and you can start walking through that if
you already received your genetic report and myself or and or Ashley have said to you the pdf part
of the report with all your genes then you could if you really want to get dirty you could go through
those videos and look at your pdf and scroll through it with what I'm talking about the specific gene
families and it could be a real great educational moment for you if you get tired of watching
baby area or something like that then this gives you something else to do all right so we are
going to open it up to questions here let's try to keep to one question per person if we can
yeah so everybody I can hear you so ask a question that I will do it for everybody too
and I came to see you in May and everything was okay but in July
My cancer was active again in my upper chest, but the hemography says that
the left upper chest was inflamed. This showed up on my right side. Why wasn't that shown on the
thermography? I don't know. I'm going to mute everybody here so I can hear. I don't know. So what's
going to what you're going to see on the thermography is what is metabolically active right at the time
that you take that picture. So it is it is extremely sensitive and I've told many of you before
that one we first got the thermography and wanted to see how sensitive is. So I took a picture of
the wall and of course there was no heat really coming off of the wall. All that it is put my hand
on the wall. Hardly touching the wall took my hand off took another picture and you could see my
hand is if my hand was there. So it it picked up that heat just from my hand on the wall. It is
picking up heat. So it is going to pick up any greater heat in your body which could be due to
the inflammatory process or if I'm any literal if you just poked yourself you're going to see that
heat from your hand picked up. That's why you have to be careful before we do the thermography.
There could have been you know so there's all sorts of explanations why oh how come I didn't see the
heated by colon cancer. Well if it's too deep that it's not creating heat at the surface you're not
going to see it on thermography. So it's only going to show it what's happening at the surface
but you can look at the surface and get some idea what's taking place deep inside.
So that's the benefit of using you know if you want to use thermography to it's best benefit you
want to use it fairly regularly and I know a lot of people will do breast screenings on an annual
basis if they don't have breast cancer which seems to be adequate but it's it's inexpensive enough
to do it more regularly so the more regular you could do it the better and we've even had patients
that were local that we would take pictures on a much more regular basis and not submit them to be
read which that's where the expense comes in as we have to have them read by a radiologist.
Okay any other questions?
You want to see all the phones?
Bethane you're going to let me off early tonight?
You know since no one else has any questions I got more.
The thermography I have this is my third one and so you had some they had some comparisons to it
but that's okay I got another one I was recently listening to people about
airway obstructions and then we're seeing that all our everything that you know read about cancer
clear your mouth up get your dental things all in order and everything and this so you can treat your
cancer and make sure and then you also concentrate on the colon if you have sleep apnea and TMJ
does this affect our cancer?
Yeah a sleep apnea and TMJ.
Yeah so TMJ I would say no not so much so temporal but your TMJ is your temporal and
tubular joints that's your jaw your jaw joint so TMJ is a term used for any dysfunction of that
joint that's usually a structural dysfunction for the person not in there they have muscle weakness
there's all sorts of different causes to that but that's not necessarily going to be tied to
cancer in any way. Infections in the mouth yes are tied to cancer very often.
It's a heart disease very often as well there's numerous research studies that show that
sleep apnea is totally different so sleep apnea has to do with partly we're going to
mute everybody here partly sleep apnea has to do with a neurological component in the brain where the
person stops breathing at night now there's many different theories of sleep apnea it's part of
the hapeguatus the person has extra weight gain increased expansion of the larynx to a straight
neurological cause in the in the breathing centers of the brain but regardless of what the cause is
it's going to cause a decreased oxygenation while the person's sleeping and that could be a
leading cause of a lot of problems especially you start thinking of all cybers and Parkinson's
in brain-based issues like that. How would it tie into cancer? Well if you have a decreased oxygenation
of tissues you're going to have tissues cancer cells functioning and thriving more through the warberg
effect which was discovered by auto warberg back almost a hundred years ago where cancer cells
kid feed off of and learn to live in an anaerobic leading the lack of oxygen
condition where they're feeding off of lactic acid. So you could potentially by having sleep apnea
be not helping your cancer would I say sleep apnea would be a cause of cancer? I would say
most likely not would a person with sleep apnea not be helping themselves heal from cancer if they're
not using their CPAP machine I would say it certainly can be a contributor you need to get proper
oxygenation in your tissues in order to be able to help kill cancer. I've said it multiple times
that an oxygenated tumor is a dying tumor so that's the idea of using
getting out and getting oxygenation getting some exercise doing hyperbaric oxygen therapy
you're increasing the oxygenation to the tumor and you're increasing that cell that response to
the tumor. So make sure you're not neglected your sleep apnea if that is an issue.
But I continue with the ALF device. I bless for being able to handle her.
I am the scientist on his name and he's been speaking again. I have to get that. I have to email
him that he's been helping a lot of maladyformed children open up their airway.
So that they get the proper oxygen reading technique and stuff and I just didn't know if that would
be a route to help oxygenate ourselves so that we wouldn't be you know unoccupied in contributing
cancer so that that was my question. Okay. This name's a doctor. So helping to oxygenate the
cancer help you to increase oxygenation is beneficial and that's what we talk about
kind of exercise as a cancer patient want to do. They want to do an exercise that's going to
increase oxygenation but maybe that do heavy aerobic exercise where they're leaving their tissues
in a hypoxic state. So maybe that's not the best exercise for a cancer patient you want to
be out walking, getting some exercise, getting breathing, but not
fighting yourself completely out of breath, painting, working out for her to run a marathon.
Okay. This name is Dr. Derek Nordstrom from Norway and he just came up with this.
I'll tell you what, would that be a good therapy to get involved with?
So you want to exercise with oxygen therapy. Yep, that can be a good thing. You're using a typically
you want you're using some sort of source of external oxygen like an oxygen tank or
or a oxygen concentrator and then you're walking out a treadmill or riding out a stationary bike
while you're breathing in a greater concentration of oxygen that could be another great tool.
Thank you. Okay. Anybody else with any other questions?
Hello, Donna. Hello.
I'm going to close and I just had my blood work done if the oncologist and my
camp my calcium is way out of range at 11.2. Okay. Could you could you said that to me?
I will send it when I get everything. They forgot to do the myeloma testing for someone who's been
so as soon as I get those test results back, I will send them all to you. Okay.
But I was concerned about the calcium because the myeloma is taking the calcium at all and it has
been down to 10 at one point now it's backed up and it went up again from the last time I was there,
headed blood test in April. Okay. So the concern with high calcium levels is that you have
osteoclastic activity going on somewhere in your body. So that means the breakdown of bones somewhere
in your body and with multiple myeloma that's part of the problem with multiple myeloma is that
it attacks the bones. So yes, so we need to address that and so what's that?
I didn't say anything. Okay. So we do need to address that. So if you could get me those labs
that will have a call. Okay. Okay. So get it for a month. All right. Well, we will
Yes. This is Jane and I have a question about histamines. I'm looking at your list of high histamine
level foods and I'm looking confused. Our example says histamine foods are beans and pulses
and it says chickpeas, soybeans, peanuts are those the only beans that should that are high histamine
or are you saying that all beans are high histamine? I've been watching that show that time.
Well, I put it on pause. Oops. They got it. I'm going to mute everybody here again because we're
going to feedback. Okay. So remember with histamines, make sure you go back and watch some of the
videos on histamines because it'll help you because it gets confusing with histamines. Most foods have
histamine in it. So it's you're never going to be able to hide from histamines completely. Almost
all foods the older they are have more histamines. So leftover foods have more histamines than
fresher foods. So if you're going to make a big dinner and eat it all week long because it's going
to be leftovers in the fridge, by the time the third day comes it's got a lot more histamines in the
first day and there's different studies that have measured that and sometimes it could triple quadruple
over time. So you're not the idea is that you're not you're not expelling histamines from your
diet. You are trying to decrease your histamine load. So if a person has defects especially in the
ABP1 genes that break down histamine in the gut by secreting the DAO enzyme, that means defects in
that gene. I don't have a lot of histamine breakdown enzyme in my gut. Then you want to decrease your
histamine consumption. So decreasing your histamine consumption is then just looking at that chart
of high histamine foods. Staying away from I think on that chart are the I think they're in red or
they in light. I can't remember that chart and then the ones that are in bold are the ones that have
the our things that have the least amount of histamine in it. But there isn't any way that you're
going to get rid of all histamines. So just try to stay away. All beans have histamine. All nuts have
histamine in them. So should I never eat beans anymore? Should I never eat nuts anymore? No, but maybe
if I have issues with histamine, I'm not going to eat a handful of nuts. I can still have some nuts on
my salad. The more foods you mix them in with, you're going to have less of a histamine load in your gut
at any given time. Or if I know I'm going to eat something that's very high histamine, then I could
take a histamine enzyme with that that that ABP one assist product that we have or the HISTO DAO
product that's the straight histamine enzyme. That's how you want to look at histamine. You want to
look at it as a bucket that you are going to fill, but you don't want that bucket tippy over. That's all.
Okay, thank you. That's helpful. And I'll watch the video too. That'll be interesting. Thank you.
Oh, you bet. Does breathing food help? Does it feel like histamine issues? No, histamine is a
debito acid, so it does a dye. It's not a living organism. So breathing doesn't, like I said, you
stored it for a week and it increases in histamine. Well, yeah, if you freeze it, I probably won't
increase in histamine. Okay, thank you. Stay here at a question. Anybody else?
Okay, we will add that here, then, and I will get this recording up for you guys. So everybody can
hear it. I'll get it up on Facebook. Make sure if you have any personal questions again, just
email those questions here today. We'll be taking it off of it. You don't have to worry about
any embarrassment or anything like that. And if you have other questions that you think would be good
for everybody to hear that is between these times that we do these calls, make sure you post it on
Facebook and we'll try to get that answer as well. All right, thanks, everybody, and we will talk
again soon. Thank you. Thank you. You're back.